as we get closer to the release of
Robert Muller's report summarizing the
findings of his investigation and by
that I don't mean that we know when it's
coming out I just mean every day that
goes by by sheer math we are a day
closer to the eventual conclusion of the
investigation we're seeing more and more
discussions about how shocking will the
report be how surprising will the
content of the report be and it's
important to sort of consider the
reality that the report doesn't actually
have to be very shocking because we've
already had dozens of indictments we
have people that are going to prison we
have the president implicated in a
variety of different crimes but more
importantly the Muller investigation is
just one piece of everything that's
going on you have an entire additional
slate of investigation you've got the
SDN why more importantly or just as
importantly almost weekly there are new
investigations starting in the House of
Representatives now that Democrats have
taken over control of that legislative
body and these are serious
investigations now that clowns like
Devin new nests are no longer in charge
of running some of those investigations
and I have two new ones to tell you
about today one that has started and one
that has been requested and we'll see if
it actually starts first and foremost
the House Democrats in the Judiciary
Committee are launching a new
investigation into obstruction
specifically but this is going to be a
sort of umbrella obstruction
investigation that will include Donald
Trump's campaign Donald Trump's
businesses Donald Trump's transition
team and Donald Trump's administration
why is this so important everyone talks
about obstruction but it's often sort of
compartmentalized inauguration
obstruction or pre-election campaign
finance violations followed by
obstruction to cover them up this is now
going to be a comprehensive
investigation that will be
democratically led as the Democrats now
control the House of Representatives and
therefore the
various committees within the house and
the big picture here actually could
serve as the groundwork for impeachment
now I know as soon as I say impeachment
a lot of people are going to get very
very angry with me I'm not necessarily
advocating for impeachment I'm not
saying that if the house filed
impeachment articles that the Senate
would vote to remove Donald Trump in
fact it's likely that they would not all
I'm telling you is that this house
investigation is now the type of
investigation that could be used to lay
the groundwork for impeachment if indeed
that's what we're going to see in the
future the political question Pat as to
whether Democrats should be pushing for
impeachment or whether it would be
successful we could do an hour debate
just on that but there's no denying that
this type of investigation would at
least explore the groundwork for that it
may also be a hard sell to impeach the
president solely on obstruction of
justice when Richard Nixon was facing
impeachment obstruction of justice was a
charge but there were like four other
charges that went along with it
Bill Clinton the same thing it was
obstruction of justice and perjury I
don't know if you can sell that to the
American people just a secondary crime
obstruction of justice but maybe we'll
find out and we also may find out that
there are other crimes that are going to
sort of bubble up once you start shaking
the trees or whatever analogy you want
to use metaphor rather letters have been
sent to 81 people including all sorts of
trumps associates and family members
they have two weeks to respond to these
requests of course the lawyers for all
of these 81 people and entities will
immediately start making a ton of cash
billing hours for their work on these
demands they always seem to come out
ahead but that's what they get paid for
included in this obstruction probe are
James Comey firing the catch and kill of
news stories potentially harmful to
Donald Trump hush money payments to
Donald Trump's mistresses obstruction
related to collusion with Russia abuse
of power violations of the emoluments
clause and possible obstruction to cover
that up and this is going to go on at
minimum
for months if not even longer and as I
mentioned in the first portion of
today's program this is the 2020
election okay this is going to go on
into the heart of the campaign season
and in addition to this remember that
Eric Trump and Don Jr are part of the
new House Judiciary probe we are also
now seeing demands for an investigation
into how Donald from son-in-law Jared
Kushner and Donald Trump's daughter
Ivanka Trump got security clearances
congressman ted Lieu and don beyer have
put together a letter sent to donald
trump's attorney general calling for a
criminal probe into how Kushner obtained
that security clearance and this is the
circle of nepotism cronyism and swamp
filling that supposedly trump was going
to end to remind you Jared Kushner lied
on his security clearance forms it was
determined that Jared Kushner shouldn't
even have a security clearance he and
Ivanka Trump denied that Donald Trump
had any influence on their eventually
getting those security clearances and
yet now we have multiple reports that
Donald Trump was personally involved in
effectively bullying Kushner's way into
a security clearance that he never
should have had because of his potential
potentially being compromised by foreign
powers including both Qatar and Saudi
Arabia but once again this is more of
the groundwork for showing that the
swamp filling is going on is his William
Barr Trump's attorney general going to
prosecute
Jared Kushner of course he's not he is
not going to criminate and maybe a
better term would be criminally
investigated Kushner I can't imagine
that that's going to happen but I think
Pat that the Democrats are playing this
the right way if there's evidence that
an investigation should take place you
do what you can if you can investigate
it yourself in committee you do it if
you publicly lay out the evidence and a
letter to the Attorney General
even though clearly he's not going to
investigate you still do it and you get
as much on the record as possible and
wrongdoing committed by
Kushner probably trace this back to
trump in some form we've had questions
over Jared Kushner's ties to Qatar and
Israel and to China and I think Russia -
I'd have to imagine that Trump Jared
Kushner's father-in-law is also involved
in that yeah involved or just kind of
implicitly or deliberately ignorant and
standing aside that's always kind of a
question for Trump and I know that
whenever I mentioned that a few people
will write to me and they'll say David
don't excuse Trump's behavior by saying
he's merely standing aside and kind of
the pansy Patsy I think a better better
word would be he clearly knows what's
going on he's always so involved with
everything that his businesses has but
have been up to he knows everything that
his campaign was up to as well that may
be the case but these campaigns are
far-reaching and as a merely practical
matter I wonder whether Donald Trump
even understands all of the things that
people like Jared Kushner were up to
this is going to be what the entire
reelection campaign for Trump is going
to be like there are going to be
Republican primaries going on and
simultaneously there will be
investigations going on Trump's
son-in-law will be under scrutiny
Trump's daughter is going to be
scrutinized for her possible lies if
they have only themselves to blame it's
not going away and if it helps remove
Donald Trump from the Oval Office in
2020 then it's all a good thing please
follow the David Pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show behind
the scenes pictures polls highlighted
comments from the audience and a lot of
really great stuff we'll take a quick
break
I will speak next to Alexandre NAT UPOV
about the misdemeanor industrial complex
of the American judicial system I think
it should be a really interesting
conversation